als Gesellschaft größere finanzielle
rücktrittsanreize schaffen wird aktuell
erhalten Minister viereinhalb
monats-gelder Übergangsgeld das ist
selbstverständlich sehr viel aber wenn
ich an manch einen Minister denke da
wäre es mir auch ein Jahr wert dass er
noch Gehalt bekommt oder sogar zwei
vielleicht müssen wir einfach den
finanziellen Schaden noch mehr
minimieren und damit mehr unfähige
Bundesminister aus dem Amt bekommen ich
bin gespannt wie das meine Runde hier
sieht und natürlich auch wieder
Rücktritt von Frau Trust gesehen wird
und da frage ich erstmal Carolin Bosbach
selbst die die u-politikerin dein Vater
ist ja auch CDU-Politiker CDU gestanden
Wolfgang Bosbach die Frage ist wie
siehst du es denn mit Rücktritten habe
ich recht lege ich falsch brauchen wir
gar keine Anreize ich sag's mal so es
ist du hast ja immer ich glaube wir
müssen unterscheiden das eine ist die
fachliche Inkompetenz oder das was wir
als solche wahrnehmen würde für mich da
bin ich tatsächlich anderer Meinung
nicht ausreichen wir müssen
unterscheiden zwischen fachlichen
versagen oder vielleicht Fehlbesetzungen
und wirklich persönlichen Fehlschlägen
Beispiel wenn man nach Österreich schaut
dachte ich so bei kurz damals es war
alternativlos es ging nicht anders aber
wenn du jetzt sagst du das Gefühl hast
oder den Eindruck dass die hier zu lange
an ihren Sesseln kleben auch das würde
ich tatsächlich verneinen also ist für
mich so ein das beste Beispiel was
damals mit der Wolf passiert ist das war
klar hat er einen Fehler gemacht der
doch große Fehler gemacht und das war
auch lief auch bei aller Liebe nicht
alles glatt aber diese Hetzjagd die da
auf ihn da veranstaltet worden ist wie
der gejagt worden ist von der Meute und
es überhaupt keine andere Chance für
immer gegeben hat muss ich schon sagen
ob das sein muss weiß ich nicht und ich
kann auch nur dafür waren direkt auf
alles drauf zu springen was man jemandem
vorwirft und nicht immer alles direkt
für bare Münze zu nehmen werden wir hier
einmal ganz konkret nehmen wir mal Frau
Lambrecht unsere Verteidigungsministerin
Rücktritt ja oder nein also nochmal ich
halte sie nicht für die beste Besetzung
die wir für die von diesen Posten
irgendwie schaffen könnten es würde mir
aber unter bleibe ich auch bei nicht
reichen zu sagen mir reicht ihre
fachliche Kompetenz nicht aus deswegen
muss jetzt zurücktreten das ist mir
nicht genug kann man nicht machen
hier ist ja so ein bisschen der Punkt
Herr gerse Mann was braucht denn dann
ein Minister also die fachliche
Kompetenz die ist gar nicht so schlimm
wenn sie nicht da ist dann braucht man
auch keine Rücktritt ab wann müssten
denn Minister zurücktreten und wie
blicken sie auf England
naja das ist natürlich erstmal
erfrischend das was möglich ist jemand
der ein totalen Fehlstart hinlegt wie
Frau Trassen England trittern zurück
eigentlich ist ja das politische System
in Großbritannien angelegt wie ein
Diktatur auf Zeit wenn man erst mal im
Amt ist dann ist man auch sicher im
Sattel und muss eigentlich nicht um das
Amt fürchten jahrelang das ist auch
anders durchaus als das Amt des
deutschen Bundeskanzlers das sehr viel
unsicher ist also von daher was da
gerade heute passiert ist es wirklich
richtig spektakulär und das halt so ein
Fehltritt dann sozusagen auch bestraft
wird mit seinem Rücktritt ist natürlich
irgendwie guten erfrischend in
Deutschland hat man natürlich den
Eindruck ja es kleben sehr viele Leute
sehr lange an ihren Sesseln ich wunder
mich dass der Name Schwesig noch nicht
gefallen ist in dem Zusammenhang ist ja
beispielsweise auch zurückgetreten ja
das war dann auch ein sehr langes Leiden
muss man sagen das stimmt das stimmt
also das Problem generell scheint mir
eher zu sein nicht zu sehr die
Pensionsansprüche sondern generell
Alternativen die Politiker haben zu
ihrem Politiker leben wir haben
natürlich ein ganz ganz großen Teil vom
Politikern die nie was anderes waren als
Politiker und die auch ganz anderes
können das will ich jetzt nicht sagen
wer vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben
aber die tatsächlich nie einander
Karriere ernsthaft ins Auge gefasst zu
haben als die eines Berufspolitikers und
dann haben wir natürlich tatsächlich den
Anreiz unbedingt in einem politischen an
zu bleiben oder zumindest in der
politischen Fähre zu bleiben und das
nicht zu verlieren und ja da kann man
glaube ich auch Pensionen auf sich
stellen wie man will wenn man nachher
mit Mitte 40 Mitte 50 darstellten
eigentlich keine Alternative mehr hat
dann klickt man halt doch mal absolut ja
also uns wurde auch immer gesagt dass
Kinder zu Hause aber macht bloß nicht
hier Kreißsaal oder sagt Plenarsaal ihr
geht erstmal arbeiten und das haben wir
auch alle gemacht und das ist auch
tatsächlich habe das auch jahrelang
mitbekommen bei uns in der Familie Papa
immer nebenbei gearbeitet der war am
Wochenende die Sonntage in der Kanzlei
durchgearbeitet weil immer gesagt hat
kannst von heute auf morgen zur abgesägt
sein das kann sonst irgendetwas
passieren und dann fällst du sehr sehr
weich also bin ich total bei jenes fehlt
total aber er ist ja auch kein Minister
geworden
ist es ist ja auch schon fast verpönt
wenn Politiker zwischen Wirtschaft und
Politik hin und her wachsen ist das kann
ich auch nicht verstehen absolut ja du
kannst den Leuten nicht verdienen auch
nebenbei Geld zu verdienen ich weiß
nicht warum das in Deutschland ein so
schlechten Ruf hat lass uns doch froh
sein wenn ihr auch noch Kontakt zu
anderen sage ich mal
Lebenswirklichkeiten auf von behalten
und sich nicht in ihrer Blase bewegen
aber das mag auch eine Einzelmeinung
sein hör auf mal wie sehen Sie das denn
wen würden Sie in Deutschland zum
Rücktritt also irgendwen gibt es doch
bestimmt wo sie sagen also der gehört
schon zurückgetreten ja also ich teile
die Auffassung dass politische
Verantwortung zu übernehmen hier in
Deutschland eine andere Kultur hatte ich
formuliert das mal so als als in anderen
Ländern wenn er in England oder im
Vereinigten Königreich schnell
zurückgetreten wird ist ja auch nicht
unbedingt selbstverständlich dann
verdient es aus meiner Sicht auch
Anerkennung dann zu sagen okay hat nicht
gepasst wir schauen mal das Land
ansonsten voranbringen
Verteidigungsministerin mir geht es da
weniger um irgendwelche Fehltritte
sondern ich habe die Beobachtung gemacht
dass da sehr viel ich weiß nicht wie ich
das besser formulieren soll da wird
einfach viel viel politisch rum geheult
das ist aha und ich habe mein Sohn und
ich habe doch so wenig Zeit und ihr
wollte ich da auch mal dabei haben komm
steh doch einfach dazu was du gemacht
hast als Frau
laber mir doch nicht irgendwas an die
Backe von von wegen auch ich armes
Mäuschen dass das kaufverkauft den
Leuten keiner ab oder wenn Robert Habeck
sich ins Fernsehen setzt und erzählt
euch ich weiß ja gar nicht mehr wie so
ein Frühstückstisch aussieht so nach dem
Motto
ja okay also wo sollen wir da jetzt
Mitleid mit den Leuten haben die haben
sich das ausgesucht dazusitzen also dass
das ist so eine so eine Herangehensweise
die ich nicht verstehe Robert Habeck
wäre für mich eine gute ein guter Anfang
tut mir leid wer sich wer sich hinsetzt
und sagt ja nur weil Betrieb in
Deutschland nicht mehr produziert heißt
ja nicht dass er dann zwangsläufig
insolvent hat
also Insolvenz erklären wollte und was
ist los ist also ein bisschen ungerade
das ist also von einem
Wirtschaftsminister ganz egal von
welcher Partei in welchem Land wer so
einen wirklich einen solchen Unfug
erzählt der sollte sich nach anderer
Arbeit umschauen aber ist es für sie
typisch deutsch dieses Sessel kleben
ich weiß nicht ob das ob das eine
typische typisch deutsches Phänomen ist
da habe ich mich zu wenig mit anderen
politischen Systemen im Ausland befasst
ich persönlich habe den Eindruck schon
dass man früher auch in Deutschland
häufiger politische Verantwortung
übernommen hat wenn man sich Fehltritte
geleistet hat aber auf der anderen Seite
muss man auch sagen wo ist da wo ist da
die die Linie ich sehe das ich sehe das
auch kritisch wenn man aus jeder
Kleinigkeit die da ist oder vielleicht
nicht ist
anfängt ein Politikum zu machen ganz
ehrlich da da breche ich dann auch die
Landwehr dann ist er da halt mitgeflogen
also aber es geht dann für mich eher um
die Frage wie die Leute damit umgehen
und wenn die Leute damit nicht souverän
genug umgehen können und da dann so eine
Tirade verfallen
Spiegel das ist ja tatsächlich da habe
ich die ganze Nacht das war wirklich ein
Paradebeispiel wo es auch gar nicht mal
so sehr darum ging glaube ich dass sie
im Urlaub gewesen ist und hat
tatsächlich wie sie danach damit
umgegangen ist in dieser desaströsen
Pressekonferenz wir glaube ich alle noch
lebt auf den Erinnerungen haben da ist
doch klar dass die Vermutung dann sehr
nah liegt dass so jemand für dieses Amt
nicht geeignet ist das ist es doch jetzt
kommt darauf an wie gehst du damit um
wie arbeitest du mit deinen Fehlern das
fehlt mir das stört mich persönlich viel
mehr als dass jemand an seinem Pöstchen
klebt ja das würde ich auch so sehen
damals ist ja beispielsweise Gutenberg
wegen dem Doktortitel zurückgetreten
Herr Gerdemann das ist ja heutzutage
eigentlich schon fast undenkbar dass
jemand nur wegen einem doppelte
zurücktritt oder hat sich das schon was
verändert in den Jahren
ja ich weiß es gar nicht ist ja damals
auch zurückgetreten worden also ob das
so freiwillig war
ja schon stark dazu gedreht ja genau
es gibt ja noch einen anderen
Rücktritten unfreiwilligen diese Woche
das sehr schön Boom und da frage ich
mich wirklich wenn der ein
SPD-Parteibuch gehabt hätte unter einer
SPD Innenministerin Feser wer denn nicht
noch im Amt weil was haben wir denn da
das ist ein
Ex-Unternehmer der in seinen Amt
gekommen ist als Chef des BSI
wo Leute so ein bisschen zweifelten an
seiner Qualifikation der sich aber
offenbar ganz gut eingearbeitet hat dann
ordentliches standing hat in der Branche
und dann geht auf irgendeine Party
deswegen wird im Russen Nähe vorgeworfen
und das reicht um ihn aus dem Amt zu
drängen also das finde ich irgendwie da
ist die Latte dann sehr niedriger genau
man das ist in diesem Fall ein
Spitzenbeamter
der halt rausgesetzt wurde die Tür
gesetzt wurde aber wenn das reicht wird
ein Partybesuch relativ harmlose
Partybesuch um einen Spitzenbeamten zu
schaffen
den wollen wir den dann noch alles
schaffen also es ist wie ist es denn bei
ihnen Zeug für sie ein Rücktritt von
Charakterstärke oder eher von Schwäche
es kommt immer auf die Situation an aber
generell würde ich sagen jemand der
Verantwortung übernimmt der hat meinen
Respekt ja und
nichtsdestotrotz gibt es wie Frau
Bosbach schon sagte häufig Hetzjagden wo
jemand gar nicht mehr die Chance bekommt
also fair
nachzuvollziehen was wirklich passiert
dass mir fällt salamarin ein die
finnische Ministerpräsidentin die auch
aus meiner Sicht gehetzt wurde weil sie
fotografiert wurde auf einer oder Bilder
aus ihrem Amtssitz kam die sie in
Partylaune zeigten und sie hat dazu
gestanden hat gesagt das war nicht in
Ordnung und ist damit dann auch
durchgekommen und ich fand sie hat
beispielsweise Rückgrat bewiesen hat
auch um Entschuldigung gebeten in einer
ganz anderen Form eine Spiegel das getan
hat beispielsweise aber ich würde Ihnen
dabei Pflichten man muss eigentlich wenn
Fehler passieren dafür die Verantwortung
übernehmen und dann kommt es darauf an
wie geht jemand mit den Fehlern um das
ist eine spannende spannende these
Hetzjagd der Medien das ist ja auch zum
großen Teil der Job der Medien zu
kontrollieren hier insgesamt also genau
nicht nur der Medien aber die Medien
stoßen es oft an
sprochen die Medien dann natürlich auch
wie bei Herr Wulff das ist eine Frage
wie viel ist bei einem Politiker denn
überhaupt noch privat
kaum was ich würde sagen nur die aller
aller Ängste Intimsphäre in deinem Leben
die ist noch privat ansonsten
verschwimmen die Grenzen so massiv das
kann sich keiner vorstellen auch nicht
den Druck der damit einhergeht also es
ist ich wüsste auch nicht ich weiß gar
nicht wie das Menschen wahrnehmen die
nicht so aufgewachsen ist würde mich mal
sehr interessieren ich frag mich ganz
oft so gerade auch so durch diese ganzen
Social Media und so massiv verstärkt
worden ich habe ja auch schon mehr als
Einschätzung erlebt das muss ich kann
damit gut umgehen ich frage mich aber
ganz ganz oft ob ich das auch so gut
könnte wenn ich das nicht alles schon
quasi mein Leben lang mitbekommen hätte
darum wollen sie trotzdem in die Politik
sie haben es ja immer mitbekommen von
kleinen auf ja warum wollen sie trotzdem
in die Politik ich glaube ich bin mit
einem sehr extrem Gestaltungswillen
ausgestattet gestaltungswellen
ausgestattet worden ich glaube es ist
viel zu kurz zu sagen oder es greift zu
kurz ist einfach ein Tochter aus diesem
Haus ich habe zwei Schwestern die eine
Stewardess die andere hat einen okay
also völlig andere Welten mir kam
natürlich dazu dass ich das Glück hatte
auch mit ihm in der gleichen Stadt mit
meinem Papa in Berlin zu leben und sehr
sehr viel mitbekommen zu dürfen das habe
ich nicht nur fasziniert sondern ich
habe auch gemerkt wie nötig es ist das
tatsächlich so weil die allermeisten
Menschen in meinem Umfeld so wie ich
auch aufgewachsen bin wir sind so auch
sehr Fraktion nicht böse geballt hier zu
gucken die wir heute eher als sogenannte
vogue-fraktion bezeichnen würden ja und
ich halt einfach wichtig darüber zu
sprechen was auch was wirklich auch
nachhaltiges Wirtschaften auch bedeutet
gerade für junge Leute dass man sagt
nachhaltigkeit ist auch mehr als
Klimapolitik das geht ja um
Arbeitsplatzsicherheit es geht um
Versorgungssicherheit das sind alles
Themen die mindestens genauso wichtig
sind für die stehe ich und wie setze ich
mich ein und ich wünsche mir dass sie
weiterhin auch gehört werden auf saboh
kommen ja das ist doch mal ein schöner
Ansatz noch eine sehr wie soll man sagen
leidenschaftliche Politikerin die noch
davon träum was zu verändern wir haben
ja auch manchmal welche die nicht mehr
ganz so leidenschaftlich sind deswegen
schön dass Sie da sind und jetzt kommen
wir aber zu Ihnen Herr Hoffmann und dem
wichtigen Thema heute Abend
was sie mitgebracht haben sie wollen
doch heute über die corona-impfung
sprechen ja weil es zeichnet sich ja ab
dass die EMA den Impfstoff jetzt auch
für Säugling ich glaube auf fünf Monate
freigegeben hat ab sechs Monate
und da stellt sich mir natürlich die die
Frage was eigentlich das Ziel dahinter
ist also wen wollen wir denn eigentlich
damit überhaupt noch vor irgendwas
beschützen
wir wissen nicht wir sind natürlich
wieder in ein sehr diffuses volatiles
Infektionsgeschehen aber
ich kann mir eigentlich auch nicht
vorstellen dass es sonderlich viele
Menschen gibt die dieses Angebot
wahrnehmen werden und die Art und Weise
wie mit diesem dann doch
medizinisch-technologisch neuartigen
Impfstoff leichtfertig umgegangen wird
wo wir schlicht und ergreifend nicht
wissen was damit passiert in fünf Jahren
in zehn Jahren in 15 Jahren
es ist auch noch mal eine andere
Angelegenheit wenn Erwachsene sich das
freiwillig verabreichen wir können uns
lange darüber unterhalten ob die
wirklich alle notwendigen Informationen
gehabt haben um wirklich zu sagen jo das
war jetzt meine informierte Einwilligung
in der medizinische Behandlung aber bei
bei Kindern stelle ich oder insbesondere
bei Säuglingen stelle ich mir natürlich
die Frage
wer da dann im Zweifel aufpasst dass da
wirklich keine Schindluder mitgetrieben
werden
es gibt natürlich heute schon Impfungen
die Kleinkinder erhalten über diese
berühmte Sechsfachimpfung mit erprobten
Impfstoffen die Krankheiten gegen die da
geimpft sind gefährliche Krankheiten
keine Frage aber das sind halt lang
erprobte
Mechanismen die man sich dazu nutze
macht
und wenn ich mir überlege dass
ja die Studien die laufen halt alle noch
bis 2024 wird er heftig studiert und aus
meiner Sicht ist das schlicht und
ergreifend nichts weiter als ein
fürchterlicher Euphemismus für wir
führen eine Studie am Menschen durch
ohne zu wissen was wir eigentlich machen
sehr harte Vorwürfe sie sind ja auch
Rechtsanwalt für Medizinrecht und wenn
ich richtig informiert bin dann
verteidigen sie auch Menschen die
Impfschäden haben oder die zu ihnen wie
dramatisch ist denn die Lage dass sie zu
diesem harten Urteil über die Corona
Impfung kommen ich sag's mal sag's mal
so wir haben einen stetigen Zulauf von
von Personen
die wir gegenüber dem Staat also in dem
Fall dem LAGeSo vertreten die ihre
Impfschäden gerne anerkannt und bekommen
haben wollen und entschädigt werden und
da muss ich sagen tut der deutsche Staat
so als gäbe ist die gar nicht es dürfte
ist die auch gar nicht geben man wirft
den Leuten so ich kann das nur so wenn
man alle möglichen Steine in den Weg um
sich davor zu drücken
konkret
einer der häufigsten
Varianten des Syndrom da haben sie Leute
die früher Triathlon gelaufen sind die
da nicht mehr mit den den Hausschlüssel
in die Hand nehmen können um die Tür
aufzustecken die sitzen dann vor ihnen
wie ein Häufchen Elend und sagen ja und
mein Arzt hat es mir bestätigt dass es
ein Impfschaden ist und man stellt dann
den Antrag und man hört erstmal ein
halbes Jahr von den Leuten nichts mehr
gut die haben viel zu tun keine Frage
aber mit dem mit dem Management dieser
dieser folgen man hat die Leute aus
meiner Sicht auch mit unzulässigem Druck
dazu gedrängt diese diese Impfung zu
nehmen ich möchte immer daran erinnern
dass unser geschätzter Herr
Gesundheitsminister auf Twitter vor
einer Weile noch propagiert hat er
könnte das nicht verstehen dass die
Leute eine nebenwirkungsfreie Impfung
das hat er versprochen eine
nebenwirkungsfreie Impfung nicht
annehmen wollen und da bin ich dann
geneigt zu sagen Medikament das keine
Nebenwirkungen hat es hat auch keine
Hauptwirkung also entweder der Kram hat
alle Impfungen auch Nebenwirkungen als
es jetzt nicht nur bei der Corona so es
gibt ja auch bei anderen Impfungen
Nebenwirkungen hä wie das ist ja eine
harte ehrlich gesagt eine harte Aussage
schon zu sagen die corona-impfung ist
eher ein Feldversuch würden Sie denn
dabei Pflichten
man muss erstmal die Emotionen ein wenig
rausnehmen also ich meine jetzt reden
wir über Säuglingen die geimpft werden
sollen bei jeglicher Impfung entscheiden
sowieso die Eltern das heißt der arme
schutzlose Säugling so wie es
dargestellt wird es wird ja nicht
durchgeimpft nicht ganz Deutschland wir
sind ja keine Diktatur wo jetzt jeder
Säugling zwangsmäßig eine Impfung
bekommt das entscheiden immer noch die
Eltern genauso wie für Masern Mumps
Röteln und so weiter also da würde ich
jetzt mal die Emotion rausnehmen das ist
wenn wenn das sozusagen auf eurer
europäischer Ebene entschieden wird dann
ist es ein Angebot das gemacht wird es
ist natürlich kein Zwang und es gibt
mindestens noch drei bis vier Millionen
Menschen in unserem Land die aufs
weltanschaulichen Gründen sagen ich
möchte nicht geimpft werden oder ich
warte auf den russischen Impfstoff dem
vertraue ich mehr oder was auch immer
und wir sind
klassischen todimpfstoff haben möchte
zum Beispiel ja und da wir eine
Demokratie sind dass das möglich unter
da bin ich auch stolz drauf dass sowas
möglich ist dass jeder seine Meinung
haben kann bis hin dazu dass man sagt
ich lasse mich und meine Kinder nicht
impfen generell glaube ich gibt es wenig
also oder ein Beispiel weil sie vom
LAGeSo und von Impfschäden sprachen auch
wir haben in unserer Rehaklinik in
Berlin Menschen die wahrscheinlich im
Schäden davon getragen haben von uns
Ärzten wird das natürlich begutachtet
und wir empfehlen den sofort sich zum
Beispiel bei den relevanten Stellen zu
melden aber auch diese relevanten
Stellen haben
Personalmangel und pipapo das heißt ein
halbes Jahr Wartezeit kann ich
bestätigen dass das dauert die
Anerkennung eines Impfschadens ist nicht
so trivial wie es sich anhört denn das
gehen bei re-syndrom zum Beispiel oder
andere Syndrome andere
mögliche Impfschäden entstehen auch
sozusagen denovo ohne im Schaden durch
ein banalen Infekt kann man ein
gehirnsyndrom entwickeln das heißt es
muss schon nachgewiesen werden oder mit
einer an Sicherheit Grenzen oder eine
Wahrscheinlichkeit über 50 Prozent das
wirklich die Impfung die Ursache dieser
Schadens ist und dass dieser Schaden
nicht ohne Impfung aufgetreten ist so
gewesen ja aber das muss natürlich
nachgewiesen werden sonst könnte jeder
behaupten der
einmal Nebenwirkungen also Herr Hoffmann
erzählt von dem warum sie bestätigen
dass es im Nebenwirkungen im Schäden
gibt aber muss sehen in wie häufig die
vorkommen und die häufig ohne Impfung
vorkommen jemals
sagen dürfen nebenwirkungsfrei oder das
suggerieren dürfen das ist ja schon eine
Frage die sich stellt als wenn er das so
gesagt hat ist das mindestens
unglücklich nicht war ein Medikament ich
würde da ihm wahlpflichten ja da wo ich
sagen würde also Medikament das keine
unerwünschten Strich Nebenwirkungen hat
hat wahrscheinlich auch keine Wirkung ja
also alles hat Nebenwirkungen oder kann
Nebenwirkungen haben und man muss
fairerweise auch sagen wir waren alle
sehr froh dass ein Impfstoff zur
Verfügung war weil wir zu dem Zeitpunkt
sehr dringend einen Impfstoff braucht
und wir waren uns alle bewusst dass
dieser Impfstoff eben nicht über zwölf
Jahre entwickelt worden ist sondern in
nur einem Jahr zusammengebaut werden ja
nicht wirklich kommuniziert also man
muss ja schon sagen also aber nicht
gesagt sie bekommen ein Impfstoff der
ist noch nicht
der Zeitung lesen konnte konnte
nachvollziehen dass dieser Impfstoff
sozusagen nur deswegen so schnell
entwickelt werden konnte weil
verschiedene Stadien der normalen
Impfstoffentwicklung parallel lief nicht
übersprungen oder parallel liefen und
beschleunigt wurden wo worauf sehr stolz
war noch in Deutschland absolut aber es
wirkt ja mit der Impfkampagne ich
manchmal Günther Jauch war abgebildet
mit einem mit einem Pflaster der war zu
dem Zeitpunkt nicht mehr geimpft als war
ja schon fand ich jetzt nicht dass es
eine sehr informative Impfkampagne war
sonst war Hauptsache alle gehen sich
jetzt impfen das war ja eigentlich schon
der Sog in diesem Land ja ich glaube da
würde ich ihn bei Pflichten aber es gibt
ich auch aus meinem Bekanntenkreis
Menschen die sich ja nicht haben impfen
lassen die sozusagen diesem
suchwiderstand haben deren Argumente man
sich angehört hat und auch
nachvollziehen konnte warum ja
beispielsweise wenn jemand sagt ich
möchte lieber auf einen Tod im Stoff
warten und ich finde das ist auch für
mich weil ich nicht nachvollziehbar aber
dennoch ein Standpunkt dafür mal stehen
kann weil sie haben völlig Recht auf
einmal was sie mit Freiland versucht
meinten da fällt mir auch die Pille ein
Ende der 60er Jahre ja als nur als
Beispiel so auch ein Medikament was an
Millionen von Frauen ausprobiert wurde
wenn man so will und man wusste auch
nicht genau was es für unerwünsche
Wirkung haben wenn das nur so als
Beispiel es gibt natürlich immer
Medikamente die erstmal ausprobiert
werden und dann sieht man erst was man
anstellt oder wenn man an Contergan
jetzt denkt aber zurück zum Thema
große Angst macht wenn man das schon
hört ich meine damit nur es ist also ich
verstehe die Sorgen wenn man sagt wir
verimpfen etwas von dem man nichtmals
wissen was in einem Jahr ist oder
vielleicht alone in zehn Jahren also
insofern nehme ich das genauso ernst und
wenn jemand mir sagt er möchte sich
deswegen nicht impfen lassen ist es
meine Pflicht und Aufgabe als Art zu
sagen dass es aus meiner Sicht nicht
nachvollziehbar ich empfehle dir die
Impfung aus diesen Gründen und das a der
erste Grund jemand der dreifach geimpft
ist hatten deutlich niedrigeres Risiko
an einer schweren an einem schweren
Verlauf zu erkranken also
intensivpflichtig zu werden hat auch
einen deutlich geringeres Risiko
trotzdem noch ein Risiko auch an ich sag
mal long Kove zu erkranken auch eine
Entität die 17 Millionen Menschen in
Europa schon angeblich haben also dass
das nur so als Punkt also ich denke
wichtig ist die Aufklärung und dann kann
jeder Babys natürlich nicht aber jeder
Erwachsene selbst entscheiden was für
ihn sinnvoll ist
man reinholen weil das ist ja ein gutes
Stichwort die aufklär ich finde zum
Beispiel so wie sieht das gerade erklärt
hat da hat man sich ja sehr abgeholt
gefühlt wenn ich jetzt Patientin bei
Ihnen in der Praxis gewesen wäre diesen
Chefarzt aber wie war denn die
Aufklärung also man kann ja nicht sagen
durch die einrichtungsbezogene
Impfpflicht und 2G es haben sich ja
viele Menschen unter Druck gesetzt
gefühlt also auch ich kenne Menschen die
sich nur wegen dem Druck geimpft haben
und nicht aus Überzeugung
ja das war glaube ich damals so es war
ja auch am Anfang noch so dass der
Impfstoff knapp waren das war ein
absolut gut
dass man gar nicht rankomme sehr lange
Zeit hat man Impfstoff aber was ich
geschafft das sozusagen in die Arbeit zu
bringen weil die Logistik dahinter
fehlten
es verändern sich ja die Ziele und das
ganze ist ja auch an das Virus bewegt
sich ja auch wir haben aber da davon
geredet dass wir ungefähr 1000 Corona
tote am Tag hatten in Deutschland in die
meisten auch damals an Corona gestorben
sind ungefähr 80% man weiß es immer noch
nicht hundertprozentig es gibt halt
immer nur einzelne Untersuchungen aber
bei den alten Varianten gibt man von
ungefähr 80 Prozent aus heute ist man
wahrscheinlich eher bei
50%. aber damals gab es halt 1000 Tote
am Tag von insgesamt 2700 die wir haben
in Deutschland das heißt eine
erheblicher Teil der dann noch oben
drauf kam da war damals also an
krebssterben in Deutschland ungefähr 650
Menschen am Tag wie gesagt Kovac mit und
an zusammen über 1000 Problem bei neuen
Studien das jetzt mehr Tumorerkrankungen
denn jeweils viel Vorsorge ausgefallen
ist genau genau aber ich sage halt nur
das war von der reinen Menge her eine
große Zahl dass wir damals halt vor
allem darauf geguckt haben wir müssen
verhindern als Menschen sterben völlig
richtig heute sterben im siebentagen
schnitzelversion ungefähr bei 140 das
ist auch wieder ein bisschen angestiegen
die meisten davon tatsächlich nur oder
die Hälfte wahrscheinlich das sind nur
mit und ich an Corona
ja
wobei sich auch nicht genau das ist halt
auch so ein graduelles Ding soweit ich
das weiße Mediziner ob ob es wirklich
mit oder an war aber wie viel geringer
die Zahl das ist halt nur eine Todes
unter Ursache unter vielen mittlerweile
das Problem was wir heute haben aus
meiner Sicht ist können wir eine
Überlastung des Gesundheitssystem
bekommen oder nicht droht so was wie
eine Überforderung der Intensivbetten
zum Beispiel und da wir sind bisher nie
an dem Punkt gekommen wobei man glaube
ich bis heute nicht weiß wie na wir da
dran waren bei der Impfung bleiben weil
da kommen wir später noch zu ihm im
Zusammenhang mit elonkovit sie wollte ja
also einmal ganz kurz genau
ich habe das lange lange da hingeführt
sozusagen im Moment was viel wichtiger
ist ist die vierte Impfung meiner Sicht
für die älteren weil die Älteren sind
diejenigen die dann die Intensivbetten
belegen sind halt nicht die Kinder also
wir reden wir reden in Deutschland von
teilweise nur wenigen Dutzend erst
Impfungen am Tag in ganz Deutschland da
werden jetzt nicht wenn auch kleine
Kinder geimpft werden dürfen auf einmal
die Praxen voll sein also die alten
Menschen über 60 70 Prozent von über
60-Jährigen haben keine vierte Impfung
erhalten und das sind die die multimorby
also viele Erkrankungen haben können das
ist kein Schutz bietet vor Ansteckung
gut aber nochmal du musst ganz klar
sagen die Leute die heute sagen ihr habt
ja trotzdem Kovac bekommen obwohl den
dreifach geimpft den muss man ganz klar
sagen wir haben kurbelt bekommen ja weil
sich das entwickelt wie das Grippevirus
ich sage es mal vereinfacht aber wir
sind nicht auf der Intensivstation
gelandet das ist der Punkt dass das
haben auch die Impfung versprochen wir
diese Impfung nicht von Anfang an nur so
versprochen es wurde auch versprochen
sich nicht anzustecken eigentlich
das kann sein aber das Wichtige ist
eigentlich aus meiner Sicht weil wir
über die Überforderung oder die
Intensivstation die volllaufen können
und so weiter das Kollaps
Gesundheitssystems das Wichtige ist und
das hat sich auch nicht geändert
derjenige dabei bleibe ich auch auch
wenn die die Basis wie sie wie einige
sagen noch nicht so ganz überzeugend ist
diejenigen Leute die sich dreifach haben
impfen lassen und die Älteren die jetzt
sich auch noch impfen lassen sollen 60
plus mit der vierten Impfung warum tun
sie das damit sie eben nicht einen so
stark so desaströsen Verlauf das Risiko
für einen solchen Verlauf mit
Intensivstationen eben nicht erleben ja
das heißt die meisten Kurve Infektionen
heute Verlauf die meist nicht alle
verlaufen relativ
starke Plädoyers gehalten fast schon wie
im Gerichtssaal auch sehr lange wie
Rechtsanwälte jetzt fragen wir doch mehr
Hoffmann ob er jetzt überzeugt ist sie
haben jetzt zwei leidenschaftliche
gehört warum sieben Unrecht sind also
das ist ja das ist ja aus meiner Sicht
eigentlich auch nichts neues das sind ja
die Sachen die man die man jetzt auch
medial aufbereitet
zu hören bekommt jetzt ist ja man sieht
ja auch den ich den Versuch zu sagen
naja ob mit Kobelt oder ankovi das ist
ja auch gar nicht so so wichtig weil das
löst ja den gleichen Lauterbach ja genau
lösterding im Krankenhaus den gleichen
Arbeitsaufwand aus und das ist wir ich
sag nur wie es kommuniziert wird und
diese Außenkommunikation ist der Teil
der der mich der mich daran stört und
wir haben in den letzten Jahren aus
meiner Sicht
in erheblichen Teilen ungefähr 70 Jahre
medizinetik über Bord geworfen was sind
die informierte Einwilligungen ärztliche
Heilbehandlung angeht da führt aus
meiner aus meiner Sicht kein Weg dran
vorbei ich habe unlauteren Druck auf
Leute ausgeübt mit 2G mit Nachweisen mit
diesem mit jenem ich konnte nur da rein
wenn ich wenn ich wenn ich geimpft bin
und wenn ich meinen meinen
Gesundheitsausweis der
Arbeitsplatzverlust bei der
einrichtungsbezogenen Impfpflicht oder
durchgesetzt
Universitäten die Medizin studiert haben
da wurde aber ganz gehöriger Druck
gemacht dass sie sonst aus meiner
Semester Ausscheiden mein
Physiotherapeut zum Beispiel ist nicht
mehr mein Physiotherapeut wegen der
einrichtungsbezogenen Impfpflicht nicht
weil ich darauf bestanden hätte mir wäre
das völlig egal gewesen aber sie impfen
lässt oder nicht aber er durfte vom
Staat her nicht mehr also das ist nicht
richtig das ist auf die Menschen wurde
Druck ohne Ende gemacht dann muss man
anderes Beispiel mal kurz einschieben
Masernimpfung niemand kann im
Gesundheitssystem Arbeiten der nicht
gegen Masern gibt es aus ähnlichen
Gründen
das ist etwas wo man auch argumentieren
kann wieso hat er der Mensch vorher
Lauterbach wieso hat er das so
durchgesetzt weil Masern oder warum muss
auch in Kitas jedes Kind gegen Magdeburg
fahren
das ist nur ein Beispiel dafür dass es
da kann man auch schon sagen das ist
auch ein Druck der ausgeübt wurde weil
das ist ja auch fast ein Berufsverbot
wenn ich als Arzt sage ich möchte mich
aber nicht gegen Masern impfen lassen
kann ich nicht in meinem Beruf arbeiten
ja also
das wird man auch noch sehen wie viele
drin
kommen für mich für mich ist vertreten
für mich ist es einfach nur die Frage
hatten die Leute in der realistische
Wahl und wenn ich mir überlege dass wir
in Deutschland am 21 Jahrhundert
überhaupt die Diskussion einer
allgemeinen Impfpflicht aufgeworfen
haben alleine dass wir an den Punkt
gekommen sind wo wir gesagt haben wenn
du dich nicht einer ärztlichen
Behandlung mit einem Medikament das
dessen Status ich sag's mal so
fragwürdig ist unterziehst dann lebst du
als Deutscher in Deutschland
illegal das wäre da dabei rausgekommen
und der Umstand dass wir überhaupt
darüber diskutiert haben das ist leute
Leute in der Politik gehabt die sich
hingestellt haben und mit einer
Leidenschaft geredet haben ja die
ungeimpften und ah und die müssen weg
also
an an welchen Punkt sind wir gekommen
das ist
ich brauche muss ja ein bisschen den
timekeeper heute machen ich merke schon
wir sind hier heute sehr Leidenschaft
unterwegs weil jetzt kommen wir erstmal
zu longkowitz dass sie mich das Thema
von Herr Wiehl heute und das ist ja auch
einer der Gründe warum auch viele
Politiker sehr viel Angst hatten weil
gibt es ja
also ich denke auch hier sollte man
versuchen Emotionen ein wenig
rauszunehmen was die erste Frage ist was
ist longkowitz und auch da gibt's von
der WHU an who eine gewisse Definition
es gibt auch den Begriff des postcode
unter longkowitz versteht man landläufig
sozusagen Symptome die mindestens 3
Monate nach durchgemacht der Infektion
noch da sind und auch länger bleiben bis
zu ja oder noch länger das heißt es gibt
also Menschen die machen eine Infektion
durch genesen komplett und nach einer
gewissen Zeit entwickeln sie dann
trotzdem Symptome es gibt auch Menschen
sind schwer betroffen die sind häufiger
von dem longkurve-syndrom betroffen sind
auf Intensivstationen genesen nur
teilweise und haben Symptome welche
Symptome sind das es geht los mit anos
me also mit mit Riechstörung es geht
weiter über
Gedächtnisstörung kognitive
Einschränkungen und endet mit dem
schönen Begriff der fatig die werden
dann dem in der Neurologie und auch in
der normalen Presse kennen also
überbordende Müdigkeit die einen dazu
bringt nicht mehr richtig seinen Ablauf
zu bewältigen wenn man ich spreche jetzt
als Neurologe als neurologischer Sicht
natürlich gibt es andere Symptome wie
Atemnot Kurzatmigkeit das haben auch
viele Menschen die Kurve durchgemacht
haben und später dann der Triathlet ja
nicht mehr seinem Sport nachgehen kann
ja die top-fitte Krankenschwester die
wie sie eben sagten dann den Schlüssel
nicht mehr im Schloss drehen kann auch
da möchte ich noch mal auf die Emotionen
ein wenig rausnehmen wichtig ist mir
dass man anerkennt dass es Symptome gibt
die uns dazu verleiten diesen diesen
Begriff des longkowitz zu geben und wir
müssen heutzutage von ärztlicher Seite
differenzieren was ist longkowit genau
ich als Neurologe kann Nachweis und kann
sagen es gibt Studien vermehrt dieses
Jahres in Nature veröffentlicht dass die
Symptome die das Gehirn betreffen also
die riechschwierig Schwierigkeit
Gedächtnisstörung
merkfähigkeitsstörungen da gibt es
Korrelate im Gehirn wir können also
langsam nachweisen dass etwas ob es das
Virus ist oder eine Reaktion auf das
Virus Gehirnstrukturen verändert und zu
einer gewissen Schrumpfung in gewissen
Hirnarealen
wir haben endlich einen korrelator er
sagen können diese Menschen die schwer
betroffen sind da können wir sehen was
sie haben aber wir wissen immer noch
nicht warum das passiert das heißt wenn
man keine richtige Diagnose kein
richtiges Verständnis hat es ist eine
inflammation es ist eine Infektion mit
dem Virus mit Virus Partikeln ist es
eine Reaktion darauf also das haben wir
alles noch nicht verstanden also sind
wir als Ärzte mit Symptom konfrontiert
die nicht spezifisch sind Müdigkeit gibt
es auch bei der MS Multiple Sklerose
Müdigkeit gibt es auch beim depressiven
Menschen Müdigkeit oder oder auch
merkfähigkeitsstörungen gibt es auch bei
Menschen die Drogen genommen haben die
eine Entwicklung zu einer Demenz haben
was ich damit sagen will ist es tut uns
nicht gut dass wir sozusagen jeder der
zu uns kommt jedem sozusagen dieses
diese Diagnose auch anheften wir müssen
differenzieren wir müssen andere
Erkrankungen erstmal ausschließen
solange wir nicht an biomarke haben für
diese Erkrankung zum Beispiel für die MS
kann man sagen bei der und der
Konstellation der Bildgebung und so
weiter zusammenfassen würde dann sagen
sie eigentlich das vielleicht zu schnell
da die sie Aussage ist genau weil weil
wir immer noch keine richtig wir haben
wir sind auch wenn die WHO eine
windelweiche weiß ich anders möglich ist
eine windelweiche Definition hat
tun mir keine Menschen gefallen damit
dass wir sagen so wie du dich
präsentierst das ist lancobit wir müssen
also erstmal und das finde ich das haben
wir Mediziner sind wir jedem Patienten
schuldig sicherstellen dass das wovon
wir sprechen also ihr müsst eine Katalog
also eine Entität erstmal entwickeln
dass wir sagen können mit der
Wahrscheinlichkeit hat dieser Mensch
diese Erkrankung was wir momentan machen
oder nur machen können ist wir haben
neben die Symptome und behandeln die
Symptome was ja nicht falsch ist ich bin
froh dass sie heute da sind weil ich
habe eine Pressekonferenz mit Karl
Lauterbach gesehen und mit einer
spiegelautorin und seitdem trage ich
mich ein bisschen okay wie kann ich das
jetzt selber für mich einschätzen wir
hören einmal rein
meine Infektion war im Januar ich war
dreimal geimpft also ich war ziemlich
frisch gebustert und seitdem bin ich
krank
wir klären sie sich dass sie trotzdem
so derartig erkrankt sind und
gleichzeitig werden sie auch für
Impfungen haben Sie da nicht auch einen
Zweifel dass das möglicherweise nicht so
geschützt hat wie sie sich das erhofft
haben weil sie ja trotz Impfung schwer
erkrankt
wie erkläre ich mir das keine Ahnung
kann ich mir nicht erklären also es ist
so
[Musik]
ich kenne auch Leute die nicht geimpft
waren und lonkovic haben von daher
also keine Ahnung wie das bei mir
gelaufen wäre wenn ich nicht geimpft
gewesen wäre also das ist nämlich die
spiegel-journalistin Frau Stokowski
ich habe trotzdem eine Frage also als
Bürgerin schaut man sich das an und
denkt sich okay die Frau erzählt sie ist
dreimal geimpft sie ist auch gepustet
hatte Corona hat jetzt longkow wenn es
könnten aber doch dann auch Impfschäden
sein oder also ich habe gar nicht
richtig verstanden warum Herr Lauterbach
sie jetzt für die Bewerbung der Impfung
eingeladen hat mir ist es überhaupt
nicht klar geworden deswegen habe ich
mich heute so auf sie auf Sie als
Fachmann gefreut dass sie mir das mal
erklären können also ich habe Frau
Stokowski sein Beispiel einer einer
Patientin die trotz der Impfung und das
sind eher die wenigen so wie es heute
sehen also Minderheit trotz der Impfung
nach einer gewissen Zeit der Genesung
wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe
dann Symptome entwickelt hat die nach
meine Informationen schon jetzt täglich
nachher 264 Tage anhalten also sie hat
noch die fatig das was also diese kann
sozusagen ihren Alltag nicht be hat
möglicherweise auch
merkfähigkeitsstörungen kann also nicht
mehr Texte schreiben mit der Werft wie
sie es früher gemacht hat und das ist
ein Beispiel dafür wo jetzt Impfgegner
sagen würden LG bätschi die Impfung ist
auch für ein Eimer persönlich würde ich
sagen ganz im Gegenteil gott sei Dank
ist die Dame geimpft denn weil sie
geimpft worden ist ist sie nicht auf der
Intensivstation gelandet und
möglicherweise verstorben ja also das
mal aus ärztlicher Sicht sozusagen sie
ist wahrscheinlich eine der wir und wir
haben das das Syndrom immer nicht
verstanden wir verstehen immer noch
nicht warum
Stelle als testimoni für die Impfung
mitgenommen nein ich sage also sie ist
kein gutes Beispiel dafür weil die weil
sie trotz Impfung was aber vielen
passiert die Infektion durchgemacht hat
und leider dann auch und das wissen wir
dass eine Minderheit dann obwohl sie
geimpft sind und diese die also erkrankt
sind trotzdem dann das was wir als
longkowith betrachten entwickeln können
das bedeutet aber im Umkehrschluss nur
dass wir noch nicht genau verstehen
wieso das so ist wieso wieso also und
das versuchen wir zu verstehen das ist
immer noch early days wir sind noch ganz
am Anfang verstehen also man könnte ja
vereinfacht sagen der der schwer
erkrankt ist hat ein größeres Risiko
nein nicht mehr ganz kurz ich will alle
Argumente am Tisch hören ansonsten sieht
die ganze Zeit dran Frau Bosbach da bin
ich ziemlich gerne mal fragen also es
sind die Early Days wir sind ganz am
Anfang in der Kommunikation klingt das
aber ja eigentlich so als wüssten Ärzte
Politiker alle alles weil sonst können
sie uns ja nicht alles empfehlen wie
fühlen sie sich denn abgeholt als Bürger
als Bürger genau das ist der Punkt jetzt
nicht treffender sagen kann ich habe ein
riesen Problem mit der Kommunikation und
zwar von Minute eins an das hatten wir
eben schon ähm genau das ist das Problem
was man gar nicht wo man anfangen soll
auch mit der Impfkampagne das war ich
habe mich auch impfen lassen komplett
gar keine Frage obwohl jetzt sage es war
keine Frage weil es war für mich war
eine Frage und genau aus diesem Grund
weil ich mich überhaupt nicht aufgeklärt
gefühlt habe weil ich zu denjenigen
gehört habe soll ich eine sehr sehr
große Gruppe an Menschen gewesen die
gesagt haben wir sind keine Schwur bla
keine Leugner keine Skeptik aber wir
dürfen noch mal kritisch nachfragen wenn
diese Fragen nicht beantwortet werden
du das nicht gerade das Vertrauen in
bestimmte Maßnahmen das gleiche was wir
eben gehört haben wie geht man denn dann
wieder der Punkt wie gehst du denn damit
etwas um Beispiel hier mit dem wir
wissen wir haben attestiert bekommen von
ärztlicher Seite es gibt im Schäden die
reagierst du dann an als Starter drauf
musst doch vertrauensbildende Maßnahmen
schaffen du musst die Leute doch mit
irgendwelche Eingreifen es gibt
Strukturen wenn man den Verdacht eines
Impfschadens hat als als Bürger als Arzt
wo man sich melden
Argument dass dagegen
alles sagt sie sagen auch wir sind bei
den Early Days aber wir wissen trotzdem
so und so und so und die Impfung macht
man ab 60 und so weiter deswegen Frau
Bosbach erklärt einfach nur mal wie sie
die Lage sieht danke so stinkt das hätte
ich jetzt auch und es ist und noch mal
das geht ja gar nicht darum und wenn das
so lange dauert dann ist es doch auch
eine Art der Kommunikation das doch
wenigstens mal da zulegen wenn du
mauerst kommunikativ von Seiten sehr
Regierung wenn also alles was
intransparent ist es per se schon mal
schlecht so da spürst du lediglich
Protest mit meinen Bürgern oder Unmut im
besten Fall wir wollen doch eigentlich
genau das Gegenteil erreichen mir ist
doch viel lieber jemand geht von vorne
rein hin und sagt wir wissen nicht alles
wir empfehlen es euch aber aus grünen
ABCD jetzt entscheidet du bitte selber
ich glaube dass das wesentlich weniger
Reaktanz verursacht als die Art und
Weise wie es nun mal kommunikativ
geschehen ist auch jetzt wäre es mir
lieber man sagt wir stehen ganz am
Anfang überlegt es euch trefft ihr die
Entscheidung alles was auf Zwang ist und
dann mit diesem Stadium dass man erkennt
eben das ist ja gar gestern eine normale
natürlich dass am Anfang Entschuldigung
reden sie von den Politikern die oder
reden sie also ich möchte nur erinnern
Herr Drosten kennt die noch jemand Herr
Drosten hat einen Herr der der Virologe
also wenn Sie Herrn Drosten kennen der
hat einen Podcast gemacht der hat auch
ganz ehrlich gesagt der Wissenschaft
gibt es verschiedene Meinung ich fand
persönlich ja sehr gut wie ich sag mal
Herr Drosten kommuniziert hat ich fand
auch gut dass viele Politiker auch offen
gesagt haben wir wissen auch nicht wie
es weitergeht wurde die
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht
eingeführt das war doch voll scheiße zu
treffen waren es war ehrlich
ja von von Stunde Null an ist man sofort
mit
gewaltvollzogen Impfpflicht gut finden
dafür sind wir bei 8:15 Uhr jeder darf
das empfinden wie er möchte hier am
Tisch und wir kommen jetzt zu ihnen
genau genau ich würde nämlich sagen wir
haben keinem das ist ein Schimmer auf
was wir da hinsteuern wir befinden uns
jetzt schon im Herbstnebel wie es nennen
würde die Inzidenzen sinken im Moment
vielleicht weil auch schon in vielen
Bundesländern Herbstferien sind
andererseits gibt es auch sinken
Inzidenzen fast zeitgleich beginnend in
Italien Österreich und Frankreich man
fragt wie wird die woher kommt denn das
das kann halt nicht an den Deutschen
Herbst werden liegen das kann auch nicht
an der deutschen Vorsicht Liegen oder im
deutschen Maßnahmen oder nichtmaßnahmen
von daher wir sind halt immer noch an
dem Punkt nach fast drei Jahren wo wir
eigentlich überhaupt nicht wissen was
nächste Woche nächsten Monat im nächsten
Jahr auf uns wartet wenn die sommerwelle
zum Beispiel kam komplett überraschend
da haben auch die Virologen nicht
mitgerechnet die reden immer von
saisonalen Effekten das im Herbst
natürlich die Zahlen steigen das
erwarten wir aber das auf einmal eine
sommerwelle kommt völlig unerwartet er
ist auch völlig und jeder
zusammengebrochen wir wissen es halt
nicht in Vorwurf den ich der Politik
machen würde ist dass wir mutwillig viel
weniger wissen als wir es tun könnten
ein Beispiel ist es gab im März 2020
ganz am Anfang schon ein
wissenschaftlichen Vorschlag ein
repräsentatives Testen zu machen das hat
den großen Vorteil dass wir ein genaues
Bild haben über das Infektionsgeschehen
und auch insbesondere darüber wer sich
infiziert und wo er sich infiziert wir
wissen bis heute nicht ob Busse und
Bahnen wirklich gefährlich sind ob
Supermärkte wirklich gefährlich sind das
wird einfach das behauptete wissen und
wir vermuten dass das vermutlich
eine Ansteckung erforderlich ist wenn
man einen Bus und an einer Bahn fährt
weil wir es auch von früher von einer
Grippe so kennen wissen tun wir es nicht
hätten wir ein repräsentatives testen
könnten wir genau gucken stecken sich
Pendler überproportional an wo stecken
sich an sind das junge alte da haben wir
viel zu wenig Informationen drüber so
ein Vorschlag lag im März 2020 es bis
heute nicht aufgegriffen wenn man auch
hört heute Abend wieder man weiß das
noch nicht mal weiß das noch nicht wir
sind doch nicht mehr im Jahr 2020 oder
doch doch doch es gab ganz lange zum
Beispiel ganz lange wieder zurück in der
Zeit als wir über Altenheim und
Krankenhäuser geredet haben wir haben ja
gesagt schutzfolderable Gruppen im
Moment gerade unter den alten steigenden
Zahlen wieder also die Schützen die
vulnerable nach wie vor nicht es gab
halt immer andere Länder wie Amerika mit
Joe Beine haben die Pandemie längst für
beendet erklärt auch viele andere Länder
genau
in der ganzen Welt in Corona impfte also
die Virus so sehen wie in Deutschland
naja also wir haben halt nach wie vor
10.000 Fälle jeden Tag von denen im
Moment ein ganz ganz großer Teil ein
überproportional Teil über 60 Jahre alt
ist also von denen werden auch eine
gewisse Anzeigen gewisse Anteil im
Krankenhaus waren und auf
Intensivstationen und wir möchten alle
dass die Intensivstation Amerika
fahrlässig die können das machen wie sie
wollen aber ich sag halt nur wenn die
Medizin mir sagt und Medizin Manager mir
sagen wir brauchen zehn Prozent frei
Intensivbetten in Deutschland um
reaktionsfähig zu sein um halt wenn
irgendwas passiert handeln zu können und
wir sind aktuell wir waren lange bei 15%
in diesem Jahr sind aktuell bei 12%
Tendenz
die Leute sich infizieren und
ignoriert zum Beispiel völlig normal wir
sind von 50 15 auf 12 zurückgekommen was
die freien Betten angeht zehn Prozent
ist die kritische Grenze
aber das ist auch eine Sache da bin ich
mir sicher ob wir es austesten was dann
wirklich passiert
Amerika fahrlässig sind wir in
Deutschland wieder im Jahr 2020
meine meine Perspektive darauf ich meine
Joe Joe Biden kann viel erzählen wenn
der Tag lang ist
ich habe schon den Eindruck dass in
Deutschland man sich sehr gerne jetzt
noch an dem an den corona-maßnahmen und
an Corona als Thema so ein bisschen so
ein bisschen festhält einfach ich glaube
wenn man dass ich da politisch auch
daran gewöhnt hat und das ist eben auch
meine mein großes Problem in den USA ist
in Anführungszeichen alles viel
schlimmer gewesen auf der anderen Seite
wenn man dann mal genau hinschaut war es
auch nicht so schlimm wie es
propagiert würde ich meine dieses Schiff
dass er da angeschafft haben das stand
auch leer also haben sie denn zum Ende
dieses großen corona-blocks die wir
heute haben Abend hatten vielleicht
einen Wunsch der die Seiten so ein
bisschen auch vereint die ist ja
tatsächlich wünschen dass man dass der
Staat nicht mehr im Blindflug arbeitet
das was gerade gesagt wurde zum zum
Thema dass man gezielt testet und nicht
nur irgendwelchen Infektionsketten man
muss es ja sagen ihnen hinterher rennt
mit dem frommen Wunsch die dadurch zu
unterbrechen hat ja blendend
funktioniert
dass man ja wir haben das in den enormen
Kontrollverfahren vor zwei Jahren im
einstweiligen Rechtsschutzverfahren
angestoßen haben haben wir exakt das
vorgetragen wir haben gesagt wir wissen
wir wissen nichts dass das der Zahlen wo
es den wir haben der ist in keine
Richtung und irgendeine Art und Weise
aussagekräftigt kein Blindflug mehr mit
den empfinden wahrscheinlich alle am
Tisch so und wir sind gleich zurück dann
aber nicht mehr mit Corona sondern mit
dem Fachkräftemangel bis gleich
[Musik]
ernst nehmen also genannten Experten
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren bei viertel nach acht fünf Köpfe
fünf Meinungen von jeder von uns hat ein
Thema mitgebracht dass sie bewegt ärgert
freut oder schockiert
so nicht Privatchat Uschi
aber niemand von den politischen
Parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur Freiheit diese
grünen roten stehen da und führen
hochtrabende Debatten über die
rettungsweltklimas und um die Füße
rumwuseln die Ratten das Thema ist viel
zu wichtig uns nur der AFD zu überlassen
lass den Leuten noch mal den Spaß wir
sehen da etwas was eigentlich fatal ist
in der Politik bei den Journalisten
deren Job ist es doch gerade abweichende
Meinungen zu finden und sie sollen den
doch auch richtig doof finden
zu Manko vielleicht einmal kurz anders
also
das sind irgendwelche anorakträger aus
Buxtehude die das Gucken so ich habe
meinen Beifall in meiner lache immer
bekommen wer kümmert sich darum niemand
bitte ist ja man muss da ganz klar jetzt
mal auch darüber sprechen dass es
einfach nicht fair ist und nicht richtig
wo ist die Aufgabe von Journalismus
einfach die die Verlautbarung der
Politik zu hinterfragen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir sind zurück und starten nun direkt
mit dem Fachkräftemangel ein wichtiges
Thema in Deutschland mit Caroline
Bosbach
genau mein Thema beschäftigt sich heute
Abend mit einem Problem dass wir trotz
Ukraine und corona-krise und so weiter
nicht aus den Augen verlieren dürfen
weil es uns alle betrifft und vor allem
auch unsere junge Generation und zwar
geht es darum dass der demografische
Wandel den wir ja bei der täglich
erleben dafür sorgen wird dass wir auf
einen dramatischen Fachkräftemangel
hinlaufen werden und die Politik schaut
dabei zu das ist schlecht in 2025 werden
auch die geburtenstarken Jahrgänge
langsam aber sicher in den Ruhestand
gehen der digitale Wandel in der
Arbeitswelt tut hier sein übriges so
schon heute ist es so dass mehr als zwei
Millionen Stellen unbesetzt sind schon
heute ist es so dass mehr als die Hälfte
aller Unternehmen angibt dass sie ihre
Stellen zumindestens vorübergehend nicht
besetzen kann so und das betrifft nicht
nur industriehandwerk und IT man
vielleicht denken könnte mitnichten es
geht hier vor allem auch um ungelernte
im Dienstleistungsbereich gehen Sie hier
in Berlin mal abends aus tagsüber auch
was sehen wir in Restaurants Ruhetage
werden eingeführt aufgrund des
Personalmangels oder eben stark
verkürzte Öffnungszeiten ich denke aber
auch in unsere Flughäfen ja die mit der
Abwicklung gar nicht mehr
hinterherkommen und wenn man über
sicherheits- und reinigungswirtschaft
spricht die Zahlen sind noch
alarmierender hier sprechen 80% der
Unternehmen davon dass sie nicht mehr
besetzen können was besetzt werden muss
also krasse arbeitsagen ich persönlich
finde dass das Zahlen sind die uns alle
alarmieren sollten weil die nicht nur
die Unternehmen selber und der
Mittelstand betroffen sind nicht nur für
die wird es teuer sondern unterm Strich
für uns alle vor allem auch für den
Steuerzahler und deswegen wünsche ich
mir von der Politik dass Sie hier eine
Bremse einlegt dass sie diese
Entwicklung wirklich mal hier ein Vlog
reinrammt und endlich mal Maßnahmen
ergreift die dafür sorgen dass wir hier
auf einen grünen Zweig wiederkommen denn
ich finde das ist vor allem eine Frage
der Generationengerechtigkeit Frau
Borsbach ist die Politik denn im
politischen Berlin überhaupt alarmiert
genug ich war hier letztens um 13 Uhr um
die Ecke beim Bäcker ja oft Dinge der
hat auch eigentlich immer so bis 19 Uhr
auf um 13:30 Uhr wurde die Tür zugemacht
für mich gab es dann auch nichts mehr
weil genau wie sie beschrieben haben es
gab keine Verkäufer und deswegen musste
geschlossen werden an dem Tag ist denn
da in der Politik genug
Alarmbereitschaft da ja ganz
offensichtlich ja nicht ich kann das
jetzt nicht bestätigen ich kann nur
sagen dass mich sehr sehr viel
verwundert was eigentlich offensichtlich
ist weil wir es ja im Alltag immer
wieder erleben so und jetzt würde man ja
meinen dass man darüber spricht dann
über Lösungsansätze ernsthaft diskutiert
für mich wäre das sowas wie eine Frage
wie kann man den arbeitsstandort
Deutschland wieder attraktiv bekommen
jedes Jahr das muss man sich auch mal
klar machen gehen rund 50.000 junge gut
ausgebildete Menschen zwischen 20 und 33
verlassen dieses Land nicht weil sie es
hier nicht Lebens- und liebenswert
finden ganz im Gegenteil sondern weil
das Arbeiten für Sie hier schlicht
unattraktiv ist mir fällt es auch
persönlich schwer im jungen Menschen zu
erklären warum er ausgerechnet in dem
Land arbeiten und Geld verdienen soll
was von allen Industrieländern die mit
Abstand Steuer und Abgabenlast hat das
ist einfach nicht schön überlegt mal wir
sind hier bei der was Abgaben angeht
kratzen wir in der 40% Marke für
Kinderlose so das hat der
wissenschaftliche Beirat des
Bundeswirtschaftsministeriums
ausgerechnet dass das auf 54% ansteigen
wird und ich finde persönlich dass das
auch grob ungerecht ist zu Lasten
unserer jungen und erwerbsfähigen
Generation und zum Stichwort
Alarmbereitschaft aber wir haben gerade
das Bürgergeld das haben wir jetzt
diskutiert in den letzten Wochen das ist
das genaue Gegenteil von dem was
eigentlich erreicht werden sollte wir
sollten in diesen Zeiten Menschen
motivieren arbeiten zu gehen ja wir
sollten ihn eigentlich den Weg dafür
ebnen und sie nicht
demotivieren so wie es passiert ist lass
mich daran stört ja dass die Kissen der
sozialen Hängematte gerade weiter
aufgeschüttelt werden statt dafür zu
sagen dass man dass man die Anreize
schafft die geschaffen werden müssen was
ist diese angebliche Reform die da
losgetreten wird
das fördert ja quasi die
Erwerbslosigkeit wenn ich das mal so auf
den Punkt bringen darf es Marc hat
klingen es ist aber so kein Weg zum
Abend keine Rückruf auf Ersparnisse noch
nicht mal neuen Job muss man einem
Arbeitnehmer dann zumuten also er stört
mich eigentlich alles dran Herr Hoffmann
merken sie auch schon den
Fachkräftemangel in Ihrer Klinik wie das
mein Name aber auf jeden Fall genau also
genau ich habe vor einigen Tagen noch
zum Kollegen gesagt ich kann dieses Wort
nicht mehr hören weil wir uns täglich
damit beschäftigen also Deutschland
haben wir wir haben ich spreche auch mit
Kollegen wir haben viele Kliniken die
nicht mehr wissen wie sie ihre
patientenversorgen sollen wir haben das
Problem teilweise auch das wir einfach
zu wenig Leute haben für die Betten die
Betten können ausgelastet sein aber
können nicht bespielt werden primär
jetzt mit mit
nichtärztlichen Personal nicht spreche
zum Pflegepersonal auch da überlegen wir
seit Jahren wie wir den Job attraktiver
machen können Anreize gab es vielleicht
finanzielle Art wir kennen das Klatschen
in der corona-pandemie aber vielleicht
vermutlich wenig gebracht richtig viele
viele
deswegen dann fühlen sich davon
eigentlich ja hinters Licht geführt das
bringt ihnen gar nicht der Job ist zumal
also wenn ich für meinen Bereich spreche
der Job ist für viele nicht attraktiv
genug und wir versuchen Pflegekräfte aus
dem Ausland zu gewinnen ich hatte heute
noch Kollegen aus England damit den ich
mich besprochen habe zu diesem Thema die
haben dasselbe Probleme im Manager ist
ich frage mich mal was können wir tun
was wir tun können ist den Job
attraktiver machen das bedeutet aber
auch dass wir also im Krankenhaus
beispielsweise viel mehr ins Gespräch
gehen ein Teil meines Jobs bestimmt zehn
Prozent besteht darin einfach zuzuhören
mit den Kollegen zu sprechen vom
Pflegebereich und zu hören was das
Problem ist unbefristete Verträge das
ist ja auch fünf Minuten
ist das anders aber für für Ärzte und
Pflegende gibt es gibt ja es gibt ja
begrüßungsgelder sogar es gibt ja
Prämien wenn jemand kommt und ich glaube
was für die meisten wichtig ist ist
nicht unbedingt die Bezahlung die immer
besser wird und was für uns generell was
im Fachkräftemangel angeht und das
hatten sie glaube ich nicht erwähnt ist
auch das immer mehr Menschen Teilzeit
arbeiten wollen also es gibt immer
weniger die vollzeitarbeiten bei meinen
Assistenzärzten beispielsweise
machen wir das natürlich möglich aber
ist natürlich schwieriger wenn wenn man
keine weniger Kontinuität hat oder wenn
wenn andere Oberärzte beispielsweise
auch da mag ich konservativ sein aber
wenn sie auch ein 75 prozentstelle haben
was funktioniert bei uns aber wenn das
jeder wollte dann hätten wir wieder ein
Loch also bei ihnen haben wir jetzt
einmal gehört dass bei ihnen
unbefristete Verträge sind das ist schon
mal positiv aber hier würde ich gerne
noch einmal zu Frau Borsbach gehen weil
das ist ja nicht überall so die meisten
jungen Leute kriegen ja befristete
Verträge und eine andere
Anspruchshaltung die ich immer für mich
identifiziere ist dieses Studium über
alles kann uns das auch zum Problem
werden das eigentlich nicht nur im
Schulsystem geworden auf die
individuellen Bedürfnisse eingegangen
wird ich glaube das ist schon längst zum
Verhängnis geworden ich habe diesen ich
diesen akademisierungswagen ich habe
selber auch studiert aber nie
nachvollziehen können also weil wir
brauchen alles nein das ist wirklich so
muss man mal so hart sagen und wir haben
einfach wir müssen uns überlegen wie
kann kann man auch Ausbildung wieder
attraktiv gestalten weil sie ist es ja
eigentlich woher jetzt hier nicht ins
Detail gehen aber wenn man sich mal
Schwestern ist auch eine Ausbildung
gemacht ist ja nicht nur Akademisierung
bei Ihnen zu Hause sowieso nicht also
von unseren Schwestern wenn ich die
einzige die die studiert hat tatsächlich
und dass das muss auch nicht sein und
müssen aber schon und uns da auch er
oder die Politik ist ja auch ehrlich
machen sich überlegen wie kommt das und
wie können wir da auch ein bisschen
unterstützen beispielsweise das Handwerk
ja das soll heutzutage läuft das ja ganz
ganz skurril ab ja da können sich die er
sagt ja Azubi ja dann irgendwann zu
deinem potenziellen Arbeitgeber nach
Bewerbungsgespräch sie sind jetzt unter
meiner Top 3 ich meine das sind ja
wirklich Situationen ist es bei ihnen
genauso ja und ganz kurz noch mal zum
Thema hier Vollzeit Teilzeit und so
weiter natürlich gibt es viele gerade
hier in Berlin die Diskussion auch jeden
Tag irgendwie sagen ich möchte weniger
arbeiten ich werde TagesWoche und so
weiter es gibt aber auch den Fall der
andersrum ist auch gerade bei uns Frauen
und sagt also gerade bei meinem Alter
jetzt so 30er 40er die möchten gerne
Vollzeit arbeiten sie können es aber
nicht Stichwort Kinderbetreuung eine wo
ich auch sage das ist auch ein
bekommen und das ist auch Potenzial was
brach liegt gerade bei guten jungen
Frauen das kann eigentlich nicht sein
genauso wie bei älteren Menschen auch
dass man einfach mal sagt und offen
darüber spricht hier müssen das einfach
auch koppeln ja Lebenserwartung und
Arbeitszeit und das sind einfach Themen
die mir gerade auch in der aktuellen
Politik gerade unter so einer Ampel
massiv fehlen das sind immer sehr im
krisenmodus und Schluss weil wir zum
Ende der Sendung hingekommen selten
hatten wir so wenig Zeit gefühlt wie
heute schönen Abend noch wir sehen uns
nächste Woche Dienstag tschüss machen
sie es gut
[Musik]